hello everyone uh this is uh dr hussain
abdul sader
i'm a physician scientist at the
national cancer institute
i'll be presenting to you um tissue
based biomarkers
in oncology and first of all uh let me
thank lap roots for the invitation
and uh we'll take it from there
i have no disclosures um
what i'll be doing today is uh walk you
through a background on biomarkers in
general
uh speak about a few of the uh
tissue-based approved biomarkers by the
fda
and then uh move on to the uh to
discuss the tumor in your
microenvironment its complexity and
some of the novel uh tissue based by
marker platforms
and their challenges and finally
some future directions
first defining the biomarker it is
a characteristic that is uh measurable
it has to be measured
as an indicator of a process whether
normal or
pathogenic process by itself or
as a response to an exposure
intervention
such as a clinical uh trial and any
molecular histologic
radiographic or physiologic
characteristics are types of biomarkers
what we should know is that biomarker is
not an assessment of how an individual
feels
functions or survives
now the um the biomarkers endpoints
another tools resource
uh which is a resource of collaboration
between the nih
the national institutes of health and
the fda
categorizes by markers into several
categories as listed here
uh the susceptibility and risk by a
marker
are actually biomarkers that would
indicate whether the patient is
susceptible or at risk of developing a
process which is biologic or pathogenic
but diagnostic and monitoring and other
biomarkers are really when the patient
has an established disease
like cancer a quick brief description of
what prognostic versus predictive might
mean
a prognostic is an indicator of
a bad or good outcome regardless of
any intervention used for treatment and
examples of that
include like the staging like agcc
staging the t stage end stage and so on
and forth
well a predictive biomarker is a
biomarker that he used to
indicate whether treatment or a specific
intervention is good or bad
for patients
now just an overview of the process that
a biomarker discovery
and validation goes through there are
different phases that are described in
literature
and that varies from one resource to the
other
but tough is to say that phase one is
mainly the preclinical or the discovery
phase or exploratory studies
where phase two is when you have uh to
develop an essay
and validate that essay with what we
call analytical validity and making sure
that this is sensitive and specific
and then moving on to phase three which
is basically clinical validity to make
sure that
what you're trying to measure is really
measured on uh
specific tissues like human tissue for
example
and then moving on to clinical utility
where uh
you know those different classifications
that we talked about
come into play which is basically
whether it's going to be
susceptibility or risk by a marker or a
predictive or prognostic biomarker
and making sure they function as they're
supposed to be
and the last phase uh applies to certain
uh biomarkers
uh examples of that are the
susceptibility or the risk biomarkers
uh but it doesn't apply to uh all
biomarkers in
uh in particular uh excuse me for that
um
the um and this is uh just uh
guidance from the fda i do not mean in
any way to
get you through all this slide but this
is for your reference uh
some of the guidelines put by the fda
for again ihc based
or immunohistochemistry based
applications and all i need you to take
out of this slide is
uh you know that there is a
determination of the
uh risk or level concern uh by the asset
that you're developing whether it's a
class one or a class two or even class
three and there needs to be
documentation of the specificity
and the other information that is
required as part of the essay
that is of interest
i would start with one of the uh most
uhly known uh you know over history of
the biomarkers which is basically the
human epidermal
growth factor receptor two uh it all
started
back in the late 1980s and
that was started as a matter of fact
after a history of looking at
tumor necrosis factor susceptible cell
lines but story uh uh
told short that eventually ended up by
looking at her2 in various ways
main acids including protein rna dna
and so on and forth and it was a
challenge over the years to
apply those uh different assays to get
clinical utility or clinical validity
and after 25 years
the um in 2007 the american society of
clinical oncology and the
college of american pathologists set
together um
task force to look into these various
essays and
what they essentially found that about
25 20 percent of those
essays were um having errors in them or
were
uh not accurately uh reflecting what
needs to be reflected
and it only became um a good
uh reliable biomarker when
that task force took into
action putting together an algorithm for
describing
what positivity for that essay means
another thing that they found is
basically the
um whether you're testing
by immunohistic chemistry iic or by a
fluorescent cyto hybridization
whenever you're using a valid
biomarker testing under a clear
certified lab for example
that the outcome is the same and the
algorithm on the right side of the slide
is for breast cancer
is essentially saying that if
immunohistochemistry positivity in
invasive tumor cells is happening in 30
or more that is considered positive
anything less than that is either
equivocal or
negative and if it is equivocal
then you could test with the other
alternative which is the
fluorescent inside the hybridization and
other hand the algorithm says
if you're testing with a fish or a
fluorescent
hybridization and you had the
copy number of the chain uh
basically of the her2 gene over the
chromosome 17
more than 2.2 that's considered positive
if less than 1.8 it's negative anything
in between is equivocal and then you
have to use another validated method in
this
case would be the i8c so the message out
of this
and i'm sorry if it took too long for
you to to get you through this
is that not only the validity of the
essay from
uh analytical validity standpoint but
also from
analyzing the data of how to consider
a threshold is positive or negative and
how could that translate into
uh clinical utility uh using targeted
therapies uh
like drastic map or other of the newer
drugs
continuing on that this just gives you a
summary this is a
paper from uncle target in 2017 and
the message out of this uh slide is that
really that
over the years there have been few ihc
markers including the her2 that i
extensively spoke about but also things
for immunotherapy like the pdl one
by immunity chemistry but the rest of
those were
mainly done by genetics whether rtpcr
or next-generation sequencing and so on
and forth
and that just takes you
to believe that most of those are one
marker
i should say before i move on is that
the reason why we started thinking of
biomarkers in the world of oncology is
that
we wanted to move from one drug that
fits all to
one drug that fits one person or
personalized medicine
and i'll show you later how this
actually changed for some of the
biomarkers
to be complete this is just another
additional list of the biomarkers and i
don't intend to
uh go through all of them but this is
where i am trying to say to you
is that that change in the biomarkers
where one biomarker might fit all which
was the basics
or the basis for doing studies or
clinical trials like the basket
trials is that one biomarker which is
a genetic abnormality that is shared
among
different pathologies or different
cancer types
was thought to be the driver behind that
uh
pathogenesis of the tumor and hence it
could be used as a target for multiple
tumor types
and one certain example of interest is
the
dna mismatch repair and microsatellite
instability highlighted
or bolted here and also the anthrax
fusion that was
a good biomarker for
you know specific drugs
in addition when i was talking about the
biomarkers
there are different assays that could be
related to each of those biomarkers but
in this case as an example of
a comprehensive genomic profile test
which has been approved over the years
for different indications
while it starts with one indication it
might be actually the same
uh testing that could be approved for
multiple
indications and this is just a good
example of
one of those which is foundation one uh
cdx which is approved for
uh many by markers starting with bracket
here but ending up also with
homologous recombinant repair genes
which was just recently approved maybe
last week for prostate cancer in
addition
uh going or shifting gears back to
immunohistic chemistry and fda approved
biomarkers
in solid tumors using immunistic
chemistry already overviewed her too for
you
and then moving on uh to um
the uh other biomarkers i wouldn't dwell
too much on to seek it but stuff is to
say that it's used uh you know
for an indication with gleevac or a
methane to treat gastrointestinal
stromal tumors
what is more uh interesting the field of
immunotherapy nowadays is the pdl1
testing and as you can tell from this
there have been at least three
clones of pdl one uh assays
uh or p3p1 assays which use different
clones
the 22c3 from deco the sp-142
and the 28 and as a matter of fact
uh today it had the fda approval again
for another indication
uh the message from all of this is that
each one of those
not only deferred by the clone but also
by
the way you analyze the essay and also
the uh num the what kind of cells you're
looking at
to evaluate for pdl one and also the
thresholds
um and i'm just gonna
highlight you know one of the first ones
that were approved the pdl one from dako
the 22c3 clone
and this was approved based on two major
clinical trials
that showed uh survival benefit whether
it's overall survival benefit or
uh progression progression-free survival
benefit highlighted here by the keynote
010.025 it all started with
the biomarker assessment phase one the
keynote zero zero one
and after showing some benefit uh for
the patients that had at least
some positivity of more than one percent
that moved to
include basically uh the enrichment
strategy in which case that
uh patients that had more than fifty
percent um
uh or equal to fifty percent be the l1
expression on tumor cells uh they were
included
uh onto uh the keynote uh 25.
moving on to talk about the tumor new
micro environment
and this is a seminal paper reviewing
the tumor immune micro environment
complexity and also beauty but also the
challenges that it poses for us
the way i cut down that tumor immune
micro environment studying
from a pathology perspective but also
from an immunological perspective
is that there are multiple immune cells
present there
and those immune cells could be looked
at as n
for standing for the number of immune
cells how many immune cells are there
within the immune micro environment
uh but also the quality of those immune
cells and that could
come encompass many uh different
uh meanings which includes function
whether they're immunosuppressive or
activating
or uh what so on and forth but also the
intensity of a specific biomarker
uh in terms of for example the
expression of enzyme b
or pbl1 and other things
but the third component of all of that
is the architecture
and what i mean by that is where
do they belong to which compartment
which uh structure
so as you can tell in the fetal cells
for example are making up the
uh the blood vessels but they're not
uh making up the blood vessels only by
themselves as well as the
tumor whether it's in within the stroma
or the uh geometry per se
whether it's at the margin of the tumor
or uh within the center of the tumor all
of those
architectural um
structures are very important uh to
understanding the tumor immune micro
environment
and in addition to that there are
multiple markers that could be able to
define
any type or any particular type of cell
now summary of the challenges with
biomarker development in
general is uh with for the tumor in your
micro environment
uh is that specificity is very important
in the meaning that you need to be
specific in which markers you want to
use to define a certain
uh immune cell while one immune cell
could be defined by one biomarker most
of those biomarkers are
infidel and in other sense that you need
more than marker to define it
and defining phenotype does not
necessarily mean function so
uh milo depressed epressor cells for
example by phenotype
does not mean that they're actually
immune suppressive by
function and the reason why we're
looking at markers that are
uh static so the next challenge is that
you know while we're trying to get some
biology understanding we're only looking
at a static view
and those uh biomarkers are mostly
changing over time or
even by uh small changes uh by preparing
the tissue
so a perfect example of that is pdl1
which we explored
in previous slides other things that
include assay limitations is the
quantity quantity of tissue
and we'll go over those in the
challenges uh in
the slides down the consistency their
producibility and the different antibody
affinities
and the perfect example here is the
difference in performance
uh for example in the sp140 cube loan
versus the 22 c3 clone of pdl1
now complexity uh what i mean by that is
that
when you're studying the tumor numeric
environment you're really looking at
different subspecialties that are put
all together
whether you're looking at metabolism
you're looking at
survival death or compensatory pathways
all those and what i mean is by the
immunogenics cell death and other
pathways so different disciplines that
get into
into understanding the tumor
microenvironment and not just
looking at the number quality and the
architecture of those
different immune cells now
that being said uh i'm just going to
start with a
success story about the immune score
and walk you through that so the immune
score was
started as a concept in 2006 maybe
before that
uh by uh john gallo and his group in
france
and they understood very early on the
concept that i'm talking about which is
basically the type
and the or the and the um
and the orientation which fall into the
quality of those immune cells
but also the number which is expressed
here by density and the architecture
which is basically the location
and that consists basically of what the
immunoscope concept was all about
and uh to simplify that it basically is
a measure of two markers which is the
cd3
uh for uh you know t cells and uh
the cytotoxic the lymphocytes
represented by the cd8
in two compartments the center of the
tumor uh represented in
red uh as a whole and the
invasive margin around the uh tumor
represented
uh in the dark green color
just below the red color and what it is
about
is basically taking the uh densities
of the immune cells within those
compartments and transforming them into
percentiles and taking an average of
that and because you have two markers
and two compartments you end up with
basically four readings and you get the
average of those four readings
and because of the indication
initially that this biomarker might
stand as a prognosis by a marker
as an independent biomarker along with
the other
prognostic biomarkers that were known
for
colorectal cancer including the tnm
stage and other biomarkers
of interest
there was an interest to validate that
in an international consortium
led by the society of immunotherapy of
cancer and all started in
2012 with
about 13 centers around the world 12
countries
with 3539 patients
and then uh dividing those into a
training set
and two validation sets and as
a story uh made short is that
what the training set showed
is basically that um and again looking
at this as an independent prognostic by
a marker compared to other
already proven to be prognostic by
markets for colorectal cancers
uh with stage one two three is that in
the training set the
recurrence free survival was about eight
percent
in the uh patients um
their canon straight sorry was about uh
eight percent
in the patients with the highest immuno
score
um compared to uh 19 in the intermediate
and 32 in the uh uh
low score at five year mark
and um i should say the the cutoffs for
those
immune scores by percentile was zero to
twenty five percent 25 to 75 percent and
75 to 100 percent and
uh this uh state valid and uh
the uh two uh controls the internal
validation set and the external
validation set
and the main message out of uh this is
that the
immunoscore was independent was an
independent
prognostic marker for stages one two
three colorectal cancer
independent of other prognostic factors
including the
microsatellite instability the t and n
and uh tnn stages and
uh age gender and other uh factors
uh but also when they looked into stage
two alone that stood
uh valid as well
now the society of immunotherapy of
cancer
in 2006 put together a seminal paper
looking into what are the platforms used
to evaluate
the geometry micro environment whether
peripherally
or at the tumor level and
there has been a concept that still is
thought of as valid there are two types
of
tumors the immunologically unresponsive
called
cold can of tumor versus the logically
responsive or hot tumors
and these were defined by various
findings from different platforms used
but what stands out that in 2006 that
the
multicolor immunistic chemistry and
which i will be referring
to as multiplex if or multiplex
immunofluorescence which takes
uh into consideration uh multiple
platforms
which share the same concept that you
have you're using multiple
antibodies or multiple cycles of these
antibodies on the same slide
which makes the ability to look into
biomarkers that are
co-localized or close to each other
better or
simpler or more effective and
uh from that basically i'll move on to
explain what is multiplexing
fluorescence means and why is it
important
so focusing on novel technologies uh
first with amino fluorescence
multiplexing fluorescence or multiplex
if
i'm going to go over the concept and
show you a demo and in this
example uh here what you're showing what
we're showing is
different cells that have different
epitopes uh represented by the colors uh
blue for cd20 cb8
with lighter blue or sam blue and so on
and forth
that will be stained by primary
antibodies and then followed by
secondary antibodies which have
horseradish peroxidase
that will catalytically make those
different fluorophores
represented by the various colors
covalently bind to
the residues around the epitopes uh that
are targeted by those primary antibodies
but the key to this uh staining method
is
uh which is developed by perkin elmer
now um
both by uh scientist is that
the way to get rid of the species to
species interaction
is by denaturing the uh
immunoglobulins or the antibodies the
primary and the second antibodies using
heat and in this
uh demonstration it's been shown as
microwave treatment but it could be done
with various methods that
heat up the tissue and i'll show you the
demonstration
where primary secondary followed by
fluorescence
staining as a signal detection followed
by
the second antibody the third antibody
and
the the fourth antibody and the fifth
antibody
in in this case uh or the fourth
antibody that
is shared between these two cells and uh
this would allow that one cell could be
uh presenting with two different
biomarkers that are shown with these
different colors
and that would allow to do
colocalization analyses and that goes to
the point that there are certain cells
that need multiple markers to be defined
as a phenotype or a specific phenotype
and this is the outcome of this
multi-color ihc this is
one of our studies that we presented
at aacr in 2018 and the
the key point from that was basically
that we could push the technology at
that time to eight markers
uh with dappy but also we were looking
at
nun's muscle lung cancer changes with
demographics and i'll be showing some of
the data at the end
of this talk now i mentioned the
staining method but there are multiple
ways to stain the concept is basically
that you have tissue
represented by blue you have epitopes
and then you come with the
a primary antibody or a secondary
antibody and then you have a signal
that needs to be detecting uh you know
detected as a surrogate for that
antibody that
recognized the epidural and this signal
could be
um it could be a fluorescence
[Music]
fluorescent dye which is light which
will be detected by
basically after applying laser light and
filters and
that would be the example of the right
upper corner detection method but the
other method systems that are shown
on the left side they basically use
um ion based signals and
to detect those ion-based signals you
need mass effect
to look at the masses of these different
oligo elements or oligar metals that are
used as
signals there are other methods that use
other ways of detecting the signal i
will not be going over these in this
talk
this is a simple or a simplified or
maybe a complex way of looking into
after you're stained
uh and taking that into a a signal
detection uh platform
and as i should in in this example it's
brooklyn elmer
koya's vectra a polaris scanner
uh which is shown with the uh person uh
holding the gloves in blue and holding
sorry the
the rack with the slides that will be
scanned and you get an image which is
shown above that and with the screen
showing is basically you could do
segmentation of the tissue after you
uh do get your
regions of interest scanned again
and you segment basically to walk in the
tissue and then
based on dappy which is a nuclear marker
we segment the nuclei
and after that you could stratify or
phenotype yourselves based
on the various markers with those
examples shown here
into in a binary way in the sense that
you know whether it's positive for any
specific marker or not
but also you get what we call the uh
again
going back to the architecture the um
coordinates
in in the field by accident y and that
could be used for various analogies
and the end point of that is basically
getting a
readout with uh generation and
statistics that you could use to do
further analyses
and this is the essay that it was
proposed by programmer at the time i
will not get into details but details
but this is
for your reference if you need to go
into the details of that
uh assay development
applications for multiplex if there are
multiple applications but the
main application that i am very
interested in personally in my lab is
interested in is
developing uh that as an essay for
clinical trials
uh certainly in oncology but of course
it also could be used for other
applications including immunopathology
if you were to think like diagnoses of
lymphomas which would take several
biomarkers or several
immune markers and that could be
achieved
probably with one slide if the assay is
developed and validated for that
diagnostic purpose
now where does multiplex or multi-color
if uh stand among the um various
uh biomarkers uh used for um
uh programming prognosticating or
predicting outcomes to the
newer or to the new um
checkpoint inhibitors or new immune
therapies in cancer
this was a a great uh review
systemic review of the various uh ways
to detect pdl1
including the multicolor ihc or
multiplex if
compared to just the
single color i cpdl1 testing the tumor
mutational burning
represents dmb or the genome expression
profiling or gene expression profiling
with rna and other methods
and the the key message out of this
paper was that
multiplex if stands highly sensitive and
specific
with the highest area under the curve
area
rvc curve and that was
a very encouraging paper for the field
suggesting that uh
using multiplex iaf is really
the way to go compared to other ways of
biomarker discovery in tissue
level at each level and these are just
technical
uh uh overview why
multiplex f is better than regular ihc
the key thing here is that fluorescence
uses
uh with the spectra and the physics of
the light
is the ability to detect multiple
markers and the dynamic range
changes by up to two to three logs
detecting basically the intensity and
there is
a linear correlation between the
intensity
of the immune florescence and the
protein quantity
and there is the chance that you could
use spectromixing and machine learning
with trainable algorithms that could
allow for a
better assessment rather than just a
subjective assessment
within university chemistry so that goes
back
uh takes me back to where are we with
biomarker development of multiplex if
uh i think we're still in phase one
slash phase two
because the platform or the assay is
developed but uh there are specific
biomarkers
uh or by marker panels that are still
exploratory
and the analytical validity is still
required
and the community is working on that and
the clinical utility is to be
proven why is the analytical validity is
complex because
there are multiple steps that need to be
validated
i mentioned some of that one is the
staining method used the signal
detection tool
the image analysis platform the analysis
approach and the advanced analyses after
getting the data out of the
platform i'll go through some of the
challenges in
assessing time or the tumor immune micro
environment i
have mentioned those i'll go over the
pre-analytics and
scene and detection and in this example
uh on the right side or schematic that
gives you a summary
of uh what it takes to go through
the tissue processing from the time it
comes from the body or
issue in vivo before even fixing the
tissue or fixation
uh till the time you do the immunohistic
chemistry
there are multiple things that are
involved and uh
the the big question first if what are
we looking
what we're trying to look at reflective
biological process
remember we said biological or
pathogenic process
that is happening at the uh at the tumor
microenvironment level that could be
changed by different factors even before
getting to the fixation
and that includes for example the
ischemia from the time the biopsy is
taken out or the tissue is taken out to
the time that you're
fixing the tissue on top of that the
tissue manipulation which is basically
after the biopsy is taken and you're
fixing the tissue the type of fixation
you're using
which is mostly what we use is forming
in fixation and we embed in paraffin the
tissue
is that it actually crosslinks the
antigens or the epitopes and what
happens is that you need to
uh do antigen retrieval methods um
and that could be successful or not
successful and if it's if the epitopes
are still masked
or destroyed by various steps
before looking into that with immunistic
chemistry
really there is no immunohistochemical
staining that will come out of that
and if the epidurals are exposed there
are two things to consider one is the
antibody that is being used whether it's
specific or not whether it's monoclonal
or polyclonal or not so
the antibody itself could be a
limitation if it's a good antibody or a
bad anybody just to put it in simple
words but also how much of the epitope
is exposed how much of the epitope is
actually
shown up that the antibody will pick and
that will determine the sensitivity and
the specificity of the assay
and that needs to be validated um again
to make sure that you got that
analytical validity and then
clinical validity and if that is all
checked
then you get a good immunity chemical
staining and that takes you to the other
step which is basically how
to read that uh immunistic chemical
staining
uh positivity or negativity going
through the list on the left
i just mentioned to you the
pre-analytics i just add to that with
multiplex
if is you're looking for the antibody
fidel
and what that means not only specific
and sensitive but also because these
different immune cells might
need different antibodies to define them
most of the antibodies are infidel in
the sense they could be shared between
different cells
so to define cell a and cell b if they
have shirt
antibodies or short epitopes then you
might need different
fidel antibodies to define that and this
is where
the panel design comes in in multiplex i
have to make sure that the antibodies
that you're using
are reflecting what kind of cell you're
looking at
and because you're using uh fluorescence
and this is light and there's physics to
light and there's
some limitations to that physics is that
the signal between the
various um channels or various
uh wavelength might have an overlap but
i would add to that also that there is
some
steric hindrance probably between the
different fluorophores that are being
used in the sense that
one third floor of abundant might
actually block the
other um fluorophore coming to the same
space
uh with that you know those two epitopes
are
sharing the same space and this is what
we commonly uh
call in our multiplexing community as
the um
um as the um
uh umbrella effect and
in addition to that there is another
factor which is time the time to
actually do all this to do validation
but also the time to actually perform
the assay
and some of those assays might take
several days if done manually and you
could think of what
problems could happen if you're using uh
that time
consuming method uh in terms of uh
reproducibility from one person to the
other
moving on and just briefly this is a
list of some of the examples of the
various multiplex techniques available
and i don't mean to dwell into this so
this is just for your reference with
what technology
what signal method detection is used and
so on and forth and the pros and cons
for each one of this
but to brief up on some of that is that
those scanners are signal detection
like the hyperion which detects
basically metal because of this mass
spec
based uh compared to um you know uh
fluorescence uh scanners uh another
fluorescent scanner
is that none of those are fda approved
yet
and uh still they need to go through
that and the only two fda approved
all side imaging technologies are from
philips and like a biosystem
but they're only approved due to hnd uh
slide holstein imaging
but none of the immunofluorescence
detection methods or
assays have been uh validated
as fda approved assays yet
that takes me into adequate
representation so generally speaking
what we do is we take representative
regions of interest or fields of view
and typically at 20x or 40x and
we move on from there to take basically
averages
uh basically representing different
tumor uh areas or different
uh geometry micro environment areas and
so on and forth
uh and then the question becomes uh you
know which is an open-ended question
how many of these fovs or regions of
interest do you need
and whether you know you're really
representing
by taking those various
um randomly selected areas within the
uh specific compartment or specific
tumor
and this question was asked by
dr rem and his group at yale
in 2011 in breast cancer and they looked
into several breast cancer markers and
in this study
they looked to see whether um uh
alteratively if you iteratively if you
were to take
you know several uh regions of interest
at 20x
uh what would be the optimal number for
each of these biomarkers and you can
tell from this figure that that varied
from one by market versus the other
so while keratin for example only needs
about three
uh regions or fields of interest uh
something like map tao needed like 14
and the average is about five to ten
regions of interest so most of what we
do so far nowadays
around five to ten regions of interest
is somehow um
okay um but most people agree that
potentially taking the whole
um field of view rather than uh
i mean the the whole the whole uh
biopsy area or whole slide image is
probably better for
um many uh reasons and there was another
paper questioning you know because we
know that there is
heterogeneity within uh the tumor micro
environment there is heterogeneity
uh within any tumor biopsy and the
question is how
uh if you were to capture one uh
core would that be uh representative and
actually that paper gave a good answer
about that although it's limited by the
number of samples that were tested but
basically it shows what this paper
showed again from david grimm's group is
that
one core might be sufficient to actually
average uh those differences in the
heterogeneity and be
representative of uh despite the fact
that you might be looking if you were to
look at various cores
from the same tumor they will be pretty
much similar
so one core is representative but maybe
one region of interest within that core
might not be representative given the
heterogeneity so you need to get an
average of that
or take the whole slide to
reflect on the immune infiltrate
densities that are
present within that core now
excuse me if this slide is too busy but
this is again how to
give a scoring so after you uh want
you're after you're going after
detecting those in your infiltrates
within the tumor micro environment
there's always a question how do you
sample how what you look
or what do you um score what do you
measure
and these are all open-ended questions
but this is from the
international immuno oncology biomarker
working group
putting some guidelines in 2017
suggesting that um and this applies
mostly for those images for breast
cancer but there are some
um intricacies to other cancer types but
i'll walk you
through the uh schematic in the middle
and i'm sorry i don't have an indication
with a mouse but what you will
concentrate is step one is they're
suggesting that you select the tumor
area avoiding the areas outside or the
satellite
areas with the tumor so just focus on
the area of the center of the tumor
and then define what is stroma and what
is intra-tumor
areas and then scan a low magnification
determine the type of inflammatory
infiltrate but
the tilt group is actually already a
working group here
suggests that you only look at the
mononuclear stromal
infiltrates rather than the areas where
you have granulocytes or neutrophils or
necrotic areas
which is a valid commonly accepted um uh
uh um uh commonly accepted concept and
pathology
among pathologists and while this is uh
actually uh meant for a guidance for
pathologists to guide your report on
it actually uh presents some challenges
that you have to
if you look at the uh the um
step three and looking how many tumor
nests you have and how you wanna score
the whole
area it's a bit challenging and uh
pathologists signing out cases every day
does not have the
ability to go every single case and do
that scoring without needing
a further time and without having actual
compensation for the time
used for that kind of analyses so that's
what uh you know presents
uh you know the the need for artificial
intelligence or advanced
methods to look at that and this is a
work that is in progress and there are
new papers coming out of the working
group
on that now uh the
step five is to assess the percentage of
the immune cells and as i mentioned the
uh working group suggests that you get
actually
various uh percentages by
the compartment whether it's stroma
versus the
tumor itself and this is for uh
practical
reasons because the area that you're
measuring might actually dilute
the percentage if you were to look at
the whole tumor versus
stroma alone and tumor alone and
the in addition to that it also
reflects what has been looked at by the
immune score and by
others is that for certain tumors you
might want to apply also the
and this is the um this the image on the
right side is that you want to look at
the center of the tumor and they define
what an invasive margin
is here by one millimeter so you draw
the margin
and you take you draw the margin around
the tumor edge
and you take basically inside the tumor
and outside the tumor a margin of about
one millimeter
and again ignoring the satellite areas
around that
um as they don't qualify for the
assessment
based on this working group
recommendations
and i left that there for reference in
case you need to go through the
details but one more thing from there is
that the threshold for
what is called positive or negative has
not been defined and that has
been left to be defined by further
studies and
it's been suggested that you know most
people would go for an estimate
and that is treated also instead of
being categorical as
a continuous uh variable and that might
have its own
reflections on how to get the assessment
done
finally whichever method you use you end
up by you want to analyze the data and
make sense out of it and present it
and as a pathologist for example to
present the
uh these different
data to a clinician it might be a
challenge how to understand that how to
represent that how to
make sense out of that what does it mean
compared to traditional ways of doing
pathology which is morphology and
giving uh colors or uh shades for
uh different things that are looked at
from a morphological standpoint which is
basically the grading
uh you know or the uh staging or the
uh you know the zero one plus two plus
three plus
uh method which is an estimate of things
which is more
mostly subjective compared to an
objective method of getting data
and uh these are the different um
image analysis platforms i've mentioned
before that
we do unmixing using algorithms to
unmix the different spectra of the light
uh but
to after you get that uh unmixing of the
various channels you get to do the
analysis on the images
and that might uh you know have
different platforms available for you to
use
and then becomes if you're doing this as
an essay which uh
platform do you use and i just put in
there some of the
platforms available for your reference
so for the analytic approach i think
uh and this is a key uh thing is uh what
is the key question when you're trying
to analyze the tumor immune micro
environment i have my own concept on
this that
the tumor new micro environment
is really and that was basically the
reason why i'm
putting this message out there for you
in my mind i was thinking of an analogy
like the facebook
you know face recognition uh algorithms
which
would detect a person a within picture
10 years ago
compared to a picture from now and would
say this is person a this is person a
and then it would detect whether the
patient is smiling or uh
frowning and so on and forth uh and then
i
said uh the german micromu
microenvironment has patterns that we
recognize
as a morphologist as a pathologist but
how does that reflect can we actually
detect that can we
um and um the first question i got from
my
collaborators and colleagues from
artificial intelligence world as
do you really believe that the
information
uh is there and then the very next
question where is the message
if there was a message that's my answer
to that yes probably yes
but that put me into you know different
questions down the road as questions
bring into questions and
this is very important when you're
planning for any canada analyses
or trying to discover a biomarker in a
specific field like oncology and
when you're doing all of these analyses
you want to see whether
the pathway that you're taking to get
the data
or to do the analytic approach would
actually give you the answer
and uh one major question is if you were
doing
batch analyses and small batches you'll
get
probably some accuracy more than 90 but
when you go around
that training algorithms and you want to
do uh batch analysis most of the time
my observance and many other groups
observance that the patch analysis would
fail
you to do any um accurate analysis more
than 80 percent
uh or even 70 of the time
and the uh question is uh
uh you know do you really need to be
subjective
in terms of doing that or you want to be
uh just let the algorithms do their job
and um then that takes you to the next
step do you want to use
thresholds do you want it to be
subjective or actually uh
uh train those uh thresholds to define
what phenotypes are
and then the other question would be uh
are you counting or
you wanna count you wanna have a number
of cells or you just want to get a
density like
uh basically looking at a concentration
of
uh a solute and a fluid and you just
don't want to know the number of solutes
you just know whether
it's concentrated or not um
and also do you want to do compartmental
this you know uh
compartmental analyses or not do you
want to look into tumor versus stroma
uh quarter tumor and base mod all those
add to
the complexity of your analyses and how
do you want to present that
um in addition uh i spoke about
patterns and you know uh talking about
pattern recognition as like face
recognition for me
and uh doing spatial analyses is just
part of that
and the question again is whether you
want to let the algorithms or the
neural networks that you want to train
potentially
uh do unsupervised analyses and
dissecting the tumor and
microenvironment in a way that you could
tell whether there is a pattern there
or not and after all there's no uh
given statistics for all what you were
doing it's just going to be on the way
um depends on the way that you're doing
your analyses
and finally after all i presented you
with
a lot of challenges but i think uh after
all i think
uh there have been multiple data out
there suggesting that
there are multiple factors that might
affect the time or the human
micro environment and not only um
the tumor itself or uh the immune cells
themselves but those are
could be affected as other things in
the human being or the biology of the
human being could be affected by
multiple factors and those are known
if you're coming from africa are you
coming from a different country
that there is a variability in the mhcs
there's a variability in multiple immune
factors
based on age gender race medications
comorbidities
genetics epigenetics and the environment
with the food location stress etc
and one of the things that we were
interested in because in lung cancer we
found looking at the seer data for
example that the natural history of the
disease varies by
gender and race and does that actually
reflect
into the tumor immune environment so in
a study that i showed you the images
earlier
from aacr 2018 we just looked into a
small set of patients that were selected
to be
similar they're all smokers they're all
sharing we
the same characteristics from a
pathology perspective but
the basic question we wanted to know is
uh
do these immune mic environments change
uh or vary by gender and race
and not to our surprise because we were
expecting that
um is that these immune cells were
actually
uh different between males and females
and that actually went along with the
natural history of the disease
basically that males did better than
females
and that uh blacks that uh you know
uh uh you know uh uh
and they make a difference uh for uh for
how they uh by themselves for the race
but maybe if you put the two together
that makes a huge difference
um and uh what was important which i'm
not showing here is how those
immune cells were actually uh excluded
in
the black race although they had more
immune cells compared to
caucasians or white uh by reported race
or
color although they had more
inflammation but maybe they were
you know immune excluded or immune
suppressive
and that just highlights the fact that
the immune mic environment is not just
complex by
architecture number and quality of these
immune cells but by the
other factors that i just mentioned
now can we do better and this is the abc
or my
apc in my lab which is basically the
automated panel concept i think that
if we were to automate everything uh
in those essays we could do better and
that would be
starting with the panel design figuring
the puzzle of how to put these immune
globulins or the antibodies in in tandem
um to uh using the uh
fluidics fluidic robotics to get the
dilutions of the various reagents
to fully automated staining uh using
different technologies
and then moving on to scanning the whole
slide and figuring out an algorithm how
to do the
uh analyses uh even that validation
would
take us to basically the artificial
intelligence and methods how to do that
um after getting the the data or the
images and then doing the analyses
now automating any of these steps is a
major
work to do by itself and it requires
basic quality control and validation
so the complexity here and doing the
multiplex if is that you have the
various steps
from the staining to the dilutions
to basically knowing what antibodies you
want to use and how you want to use them
and then the scanning process and if we
were to go for an fda
approval i think that any of those need
to be
comprehensively validated and that
includes as i said the ability to do the
analyses on on these uh data
and um i'm sorry for this slide this was
green and background here but it does
seem to be changed
now the um that take me to the take home
messages on multiplex if i have what i
think of multiplex after this is a
powerful tool to dissect the complexity
of the german
micro environment it's a new school of
biomarkers
um that by market discovery actually
that bridges
multiple disciplines it's just not
pathology
it is actually pathology biology
chemistry
physics bioinformatics data science
immunology oncology so on and forth
as long as it's the beauty of that
platform it is actually the challenge
that you want to be
knowing that all of those play role in
determining your final outcome
i think global automation is one way to
improve reproducibility
quality control and validation with the
use of stringent laboratory activation
accreditation standards
proficiency testing and competency
assessment is in central
that takes me back to the her2 story and
consensus algorithms that rely on
accurate or producible assay
performances
are needed monitoring and repeating
testing in
cap accreditedly accredited laboratories
are definitely
necessary with that i would thank
you for uh watching um uh
my talk and if you have any further
questions
please feel free to contact me at left
here on the left side all the
social media contacts and i should
highlight that we started
last year scientific interest group for
multiplexing
uh it still it's an infancy and the
website is under development but i left
it there just in case you're interested
you could get there
to that website and subscribe and i
would be happy to provide you with any
resources or information that is needed
and thank you